alright so today I was supposed to put
up my video with my next assignment on
my list for a game of thrones characters
but you know what suddenly happened that
I gotta talk about first in possibly the
most wait what's going on announcement
that's happened since Star Wars got sold
to Disney apparently Netflix is in the
process of developing a new series based
on the legend of zelda so this begs the
big question is it a good idea well I
suppose first it should be said that if
we're going to continue to try and adapt
video games to screen this sort of
approach a web series or a TV show is
probably a better idea than a movie one
of the many problems that has come up
repeatedly in terms of trying to adapt
video games to movies is that most video
games either have very little story it's
a very threadbare story so they try and
Pat it out with extra stuff or they just
try and roll with almost no story and
then it just doesn't work or the video
game has such a dead story there's no
conceivable way to reasonably condense
it down to two hours now most of the
video game movies that have actually
gotten to screen sort of suffer from the
first issue games with larger more epic
scale stories for the most part they
studios seems to have been avoiding them
up to this point so I like the idea of
doing it as a series as a general
proposition in terms of ways to try and
tackle video game adaptations in the
first place now addressing the legend of
zelda specifically there's a couple of
problems here and honestly the big
problem here is link now link is really
sort of the last holdout in what used to
be a very standard trope and that is the
silent protagonist you know when the
game first came out was back on the
original nintendo there was very little
dialogue even text dialog in games
because you didn't want to take away
from the game in order to make people
read and link was just one of many
silent protagonist it was pretty much
the standard and anything that was
really trying to tell a story which
would be you would talk to NPCs who
would communicate some information to
you but your actual response to any of
that wouldn't be written in would just
be left up to the players to think of
what their character said if they even
wanted to put them I'm
of effort into it which of course at the
time gave to a greater sense of emergent
now once we got up to sort of the ps1
more the ps2 they started doing it right
when we started getting fully voiced
characters well silent protagonist kind
of went away it's pretty much just
linked at this point and then from an
adaptation standpoint that's kind of a
problem because they're gonna have to
take this character who for however many
iterations he's had has never had a
definitive voice he's had certain
personality traits he's been done more
cartoonishly he's been done darker but
his actual voice has never been heard
not articulately so as soon as they
start assigning a personality and voice
they're going to tick off a percentage
of the fans since he's been assigned a
protagonist so long everyone has their
preferred version of link but it's in
their heads we don't really know what
the definitive version of link is but
everyone thinks they do and you gotta
remember we're dealing with a Fanning
base who's gonna be screaming their
heads off if they so much as dare to
make link right handed so then dealing
with link himself is gonna be a problem
and something that needs to be tackled
but honestly there's another bigger
problem with us that is story doesn't
doesn't really have much of a story it
has a framework but there's not much of
an arc I mean the link has a generic
hero's journey but part of the problem
we're trying to adapt the series is it's
not really a series with only a couple
of exceptions every game has really just
been the first game done again with
maybe a slightly different gimmick
whether it's 3d graphics or some new
gimmicky weapon or a new style eyes look
or whatever but they've always rigidly
stuck to the same structure and
essentially the same plot every time
link has to save the land and the
princess and protect the Triforce from
the evil again and so he goes to a
dungeon we're asked to solve some
puzzles we find some sort of magic tool
which will very conveniently be the key
for solving the puzzles with in that
dungeon and possibly even the key for
defeating the boss he will ultimately
face at the end of this dungeon rinse
and repeat until Triforce is saved in
Gannon is dead now on the one hand that
sounds good for a TV shows because
very episodic you could do a dungeon in
episode but the problem is that's going
to get real repetitious really fast that
might work on a television schedule
where you air it you know once a week
and sort of space it out and get people
time to breathe and then you come back
and do it again when you do it netflix
and I load the entire season up at a go
and you binge watch it that's going to
get real repetitive real quick which
means they're gonna be tinkering with
the story and plot quite a bit to make
this actually have a notable structure
and an overall arc as opposed to just a
dungeon of the week issue having to
tinker with that story they're gonna
tick off fans because despite the fact
that it's an incredibly simplistic story
and you'd think that would give you the
freedom and the leeway to actually do
something with it I don't think there's
anyone as unforgiving and as severely
overreacting as video game fans right
now they do not like you messing with
their stuff and Zelda as a property is
just kind of in a weird place because
it's really going to need a strong
artistic hand and someone with the real
strength of their convictions willing to
graft new story probably new characters
because the repeat characters that we've
got I mean you need zelda link Gannon
but most of the other repeat characters
likes a tingle I want to see that guy
ever so they're gonna have to invent new
characters as well which is also going
to take off the fans but this is gonna
need to be guided with somebody who is
strong enough and confident enough to
make these changes and to bring
something new and different to the
proceedings but I don't know what that
Nintendo's actually going to allow that
to happen because again remember they
pretty much gave the makers of the Super
Mario brother movie carte blanche to do
whatever it was they wanted to do and
they did and the result was a disaster
my inclination would be Nintendo would
only be agreeing to this if they were
allowed much stronger control over what
was going on but if they're gonna keep
it closer to the source material that's
just going to invite all these
weaknesses that I've talked about that
just don't lend themselves to an
adaptation do you need to have the
freedom to change all these things
otherwise it's never gonna work I
suppose the other thing is how much
money are they willing to spend on this
because remember this is a big fantasy
world and if they're willing to throw
say game of thrones money behind it
could really be epic and awesome but if
they're hedging their bets on the budget
this could really look like crap or it
could be all green screen or all just
set in forest because they don't have to
build a force they can just stick elf
ears on a guy and make him walk around
it for a bit so I'm not particularly
optimistic about that I have a tendency
to end up that way whenever these
announcements come down the pike now the
more we learn maybe I'll get into a
better place with it but right now
unless they were putting somebody with a
strong artistic vision at the head of
this thing which right now we don't know
if that's the case or not and they're
prepared to spend some serious money on
it again we have no idea I just don't
see how this is gonna work out but we'll
see i'll be keeping an eye on it it'll
be an interesting development because if
it does work then we've got a new outlet
that will possibly eventually get us
some good or even great video game
adaptations on the other hand if this
thing happens and it stinks well that's
sort of one more closed door what are
your thoughts on this aside from Zelda
what is a game that you think would make
a great Netflix tile TV series speaking
personally I think this format would
really work for god of war but what do
you think whatever it is drop something
down in the comments and let's talk
about it until next time this council is
adjourned
you